kevin clark
i i have been a big fan of this
gentleman for quite some time so i need
kevin to come in and drop knowledge how
you how you feel about this uh potential
marriage between uh the seahawks and
antonio bra
i don't love it because i start to think
about the fact you basically have to
take the clues that smart teams give you
in this league and bill belichick and
robert kraft gave up on antonio brown
when obviously all the allegations came
out as soon as he signed played one game
in miami
the pittsburgh steelers who i think by
the way mike tomlin should get about
five coach of the year awards for
retroactively for how he handled love
belle and antonio brown and then you
know say what you all about the raiders
but i think john green and mike mayok
are pretty good football guys and they
gave up as well and so you look at
seattle which is all about culture all
about competing all this stuff uh dk
metcalf is really really good i don't
think that there's such a desperate need
there that you would run the risk of
derailing your season in a year where i
think the ceos can make the super bowl
just for basically taking a flyer on a
guy with this much combustible potential
i i don't i don't love it at all um i
don't care who he's friends with in that
locker room i just think when a bunch of
good teams tell you what they think of
antonio brown don't be the team that
thinks you you're smarter than that
and michael you and i may work together
well michael you and i may work together
well but as you know sometimes people
need to just be friends like it's okay
to be friends when you actually got to
work together
that's a different set of stresses you
know
now i'm going to say mike and kevin uh
speaking of smart
now keep in mind antonio brown gave us
pearls of wisdom in a tweet remember his
tweet he had this uh one line he said
look if her mama smoked newports leave
her alone that was his little
message uh to the world so that's good
advice right there but in all
seriousness okay let's say you don't
think he's a good fit in seattle
burn to prison pittsburgh
torch the bridge in oakland
um
new england uh it may be split because i
don't think bill belichick really wanted
to move on that was more robert crap
what is a good fit
what's a good fit for antonio brown in
your opinion
i think he has to go someplace away from
a competing team right now and just
rehabilitate his image um i mean i guess
if seattle wants to take the flyer and
think he's a fit fine they'll take on
that risk but i'm not if i'm a competing
team and i'm a good franchise right now
i'm letting him go someplace
like jacksonville or cincinnati or
something like that and play a year and
make sure that he can fit into a locker
room right now because he was such a
disaster in 2019 from a locker room
standpoint that i just think he's
untouchable so from a football
standpoint he's everything you know i
remember talking to brent veach there
the chiefs gm who said that when he was
scouting for receivers for patrick
mahomes he was looking at antonio bryant
ben robertsburg that connection because
no one was able to do more improvisation
in the open field nobody was able to get
open when he should nobody was able to
extend plays quite like antonio brown
and so i think 32 gm's would would do
anything to get the talent of antonio
brown i'm just saying putting him into
any locker room right now that's 5-0 or
4-1 and that is a huge risk and that's
why if if i am a broke v who obviously
doesn't doesn't you know would love to
have that talent i'm waiting for him to
prove he can be in a locker room right
now uh one of my ceo friends kevin
said that when he lets people go
uh he says hey go be great somewhere
else
that's how i feel about antonio brown is
like whether i'm 5-0 or 0-6 i don't want
any part of him and i'm not trying to
call for a ban i'm not saying that he's
done anything that is so unforgivable
especially relative to some others that
he should never play again i'm saying if
i'm a winning team i don't want him in
the locker room if i am a losing team i
don't want him around my young players
as i try to establish my culture i just
don't want him period i i just wouldn't
i wouldn't take the risk so but yeah but
i'm gonna take that as you agreeing with
me as most of our smart guests do
michael holly uh let's see if i can go
two for two
let's see if i can go two for two the
other thing michael and i have been
going up back and forth on in the last
two days
is michael tell me if i'm saying this
fairly the timing of the decision by the
miami dolphins to go from
uh ryan fitzpatrick to two tango below
we both everybody knew this was coming
sooner or later i just don't agree with
the timing right now where do you stand
on the move right now kevin
i would have given okay listen it's not
like fitz was gonna play for the next 10
weeks perfect football i would have let
fitz open the door for two a little bit
more because you know what was coming
you know there was going to be a three
interception game this is a guy who's
throwing six interceptions in the game i
think that
making the choice now when there's three
and three and he's playing pretty well i
think that that leads leads down a path
where he can be a little bit upset for
the rest of the year we heard those
candid comments yesterday i don't know i
mean i just feel like tua is the best
option and like he's if they're going to
win the afc east it's because to a
popped in these next 10 weeks and so i
like the decision generally but i also
think that it's a weird
you know i think coaches are usually
very mindful of what happens in the
locker room or what happens with veteran
guys and i kind of feel like even if the
entire locker room wanted to where to
start i kind of feel like you give fitz
a little longer of a leash let him screw
up a little bit and then make the move i
i kind of feel like this maybe was two
or three weeks early
yeah i'm gonna uh
no i'm not i'm not so sure about that
i'm gonna move on i'm gonna you and
michael smith kind of hash that thing
out
it was right it was the right decision
i'm moving on to something else kevin uh
now i want to talk to you about dallas
uh in the nfc east i thought mike
mccarthy i i i'm guilty as charged i
thought mike mccarthy
was the perfect coach for the team when
he got criticized for his hire i was
like what are they talking about this
guy's a great coach
doesn't look like it's a good fit what
do you think happens with dallas now
that dak prescott is out and and mike
mccarthy's getting some pushback from
his players anonymously
well i think that the the philosophy of
the hire was wrong because i think jerry
jones with this roster and says we can
win now let's get a mature adult in the
room get him let's coach this talent up
and win the super bowl i don't think
that roster was there i think that the
defense took a huge step back they just
don't have anything there this is not a
good football team and they never were
going to be a good football team and so
i would have gone more philosophical
maybe tried to hire you know throw money
or lincoln riley type or something like
that what happens now well they might be
the saddest sorriest playoff team in
history that's what might happen is that
the entire locker room might hate mike
mccarthy and and yet they somehow back
into the playoffs in seven and nine so
i i i think that i'm going to give mike
mccarthy a little bit of of a leash here
and not say he should be fired or
anything like that at this point but if
they don't turn this around and the
entire locker room hates them and this
is just not the higher that we thought
it was i think there has to be big
changes in dallas i think that you have
i think the one thing now at least
everyone's gonna appreciate dak prescott
and at least they're gonna know he's
worth the money because they're gonna
see what this team is like with andy
dalton or whoever they try to make a
trade for whatever it is i mean this is
an awful football team and dak prescott
was the only thing holding it together
so if i'm a dallas fan i'm i'm
appreciating dak even more now and not
appreciating mike mccarthy
uh you are one of the best nfl writers
out there but you are also
a proud orlando magic fan yes uh so
let's pivot to the nba you gotta you
obviously have history with stan vann
stan van gundy is now the uh the head
coach of the new orleans pelicans is
that a good hire that's a good fit for
you know for zion and brandon ingram
what do you think
it's an incredible fit because i think
that almost like a football coach
michael the the biggest thing with with
an mba coach is the ability to adapt and
i think that when i look at stan van
gundy's history whether that's in miami
whether that's in orlando i mean detroit
he got too much power happened sometimes
uh and he didn't make the right roster
moves but i think that they're going to
be able to play the way zion needs to
play build a strong defensive team take
enough threes i mean i think the stan
van gundy he basically reinvented uh
pace space and pace in in 2009 and was
able to you know have hito turculo and
richard lewis and all these little
inefficiencies we talk about so much now
he was doing that 11 years ago and so i
think it's an amazing hire uh you know
jj reddick just adores playing for him
basically says that he was the guy that
got uh jj onto analytics in the first
place so everything the modern game was
headed towards he was there already and
so who better for the modern game than
stan van gundy i'm gonna miss him on
television i could have used a couple
more years to stand in on television but
i think this is a good fit in new
orleans
i know i was gonna say mike i think it's
a really good hire in your hometown uh
mike and new orleans
uh great piece on stan van gundy too
just want to point out kevin that uh
kevin garnett did not play in that 2009
series that's why they were able to
vanquish the celtics
michael michael let me tell you
something that's all
let me tell you something i work for a
guy named bill simmons who points who
points that out all the time okay i've
heard that enough i've dismissed it i
don't care we beat we beat lebron we
beat the boston celtics in that in that
easter east playoffs i am completely
content with the 2009 run
do you think it's a question
hey it ain't no coincidence i'm wearing
a green jacket today so i'll be i don't
know make me
i'm wearing a polo that's not a
coincidence either
that's right
you're gonna have to say hey kevin
awesome awesome awesome job i hope uh we
both hope that you're able to come back
and join us again we really appreciate
it come on come on back brother
thanks for having me guys huge fans keep
up the great work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports